hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
in Chapter eight of the categories after
discussing the four main types of
quality topoi own Aristotle goes on and
discusses something that we can call
opposition or contrariety an auntie Otis
and this is particularly important for
qualities because qualities play such an
important role within
Aristotle's treatment of thought and
language and being so we want to spend a
bit of time going through this and being
very clear about what it is that
Aristotle is saying so he tells us that
qualities admit of they they accept that
it's a possibility for them to have
contrariety what that means is that they
have something that is opposed to them
as a quality and it gives you several
great examples here justice versus
injustice now notice that that falls
into the first kind of quality that we
discussed in in this chapter that is
habits and dispositions because justice
and its opposite injustice are in fact
habits as Aristotle will call them but
what kind of habits the specific kind of
habits that we call virtues and vices
and virtue is itself opposed to Vice
justice is a specific kind of virtue
injustice is its opposite the other
example that Aristotle uses here is
blackness versus whiteness now it's
important to note with both of these and
we'll talk a little bit more about
blackness versus whiteness that he is
using the terms that name that quality
he's not just saying black versus white
he's saying blackness the quality of
blackness the quality of whiteness the
quality of justice the quality of
injustice
so blackness versus whiteness these are
opposed to each other as well and even
if we don't have the same sort of
physical theory or theory of color
production that Aristotle himself has
which you can find in other texts in
particular in the on the soul and on
sense in the sensible we can understand
what he's saying here and that that's
the key thing this is going to be
particularly important when we go to
look at things that don't have
opposition these are very opposed to
each other we might give as another
example when it comes to taste
Aristotle opposes the bitter at one end
of a spectrum to the sweet the peak rose
to the glucose right so glucose so these
are very important now these are passive
qualities right these are the third type
of quality that we looked at and we
might also want to think about well what
about the other two types of qualities
well when it comes to what he calls you
know natural capacities those we can
find opposition in as well we talks
about people being healthy you know
being able to resist disease and stuff
like that and then we would oppose to
that the unhealthy right that would be
another quality
when it comes to the shapes and figures
of things I don't think that we can talk
in terms of opposites here or contraries
not with Aristotle sense we might if we
extend it further and we think about you
know convex and concave or something
along those lines but he doesn't
consider that here so we don't have to
worry about that
now I mention not all qualities admit of
contraries and what does he give us his
examples here he says the the black and
the white are in fact contrary to each
other but this is not so in all cases
red yellow and similar colors are
qualities that have no contraries and
again we would want to you know put
aside the fact that we we've all been
introduced to the color wheel as
children when we had to Dobb some paint
onto some you know you know within some
lines and show ourselves that yellow is
indeed opposed to purple as a
complementary color orange to blue red
to green Aristotle is not working with
that and he conceives of these other
colors as existing on sort of a spectrum
between the black and the white with the
black and the white being what we might
call the most primary the the words that
he's using here are porous and oak rose
they're not exactly corresponding to
what we we we understand but Aristotle
does recognize a set of different colors
we could similarly say something with
taste so if we have the bitter at one
end and we have the sweet at another end
there's a whole bunch of other tastes
that fit in between Aristotle actually
recognizes eight basic flavor profiles
as we might call them today including
the fatty or oily closer to the sweet
and things like the sour the astringent
the rough you know in between the salty
as
well those are not really opposites to
each other in the way that sweet and
bitter would be for Aristotle he doesn't
use those examples here but I think
those illustrate what it is that we're
trying to convey now another important
point that he makes here is if one of
the if a quality if a contrary is a
quality then the other the other opposed
to it it's contrary is also going to be
a quality as well he uses the example of
justice and injustice here so he says
injustice is contrary to justice justice
itself as a quality so then is injustice
and notice how he decides this he says
could it fit into any of the other
categories no it's not quantity or a
relation or place nor in short any other
he says this holds in the case of all
contraries that we denominated ease so
this holds in the case of other habits
this holds in the case of natural
capacities this holds in the case of
things that we can sense you know
passive qualities as Aristotle calls
them this presumably would hold in the
case of passions as well it probably
would not be applied as I said to the
shapes and forms of things but this is
this tells you quite a lot so quality
encompasses a lot of different sets of
contraries one other thing that I want
to talk about that's important here
that's related to this is the issue of
degrees the more and the less the Malone
and Haight shown in in Greek and
Aristotle says that that qualities
themselves don't actually admit of
degrees in the sense that we're thinking
of so he uses as examples health and
justice right he says some people say
health and justice these people contend
are not subject to variations
but people in varying degrees are
possessed of health and justice and so
on the same with grammatical knowledge
and all dispositions whatsoever so he's
saying here that he's willing to accept
that at that point of view that the
qualities themselves blackness or
whiteness look you just have blackness
and whiteness but then when we get down
to things some things could be more
black or more white some things could be
some people essentially well things
could be states of affairs as well it
could be more just or less just that
means they possess more justice or they
possess more injustice or less so this
is an important qualifier and notice the
distinction that he's making between
this things themselves that have
qualities of which we you know predicate
these quality terms those can have more
or less the qualities themselves are
just what they are so this I think
encapsulate s' Aristotle's teaching in
the categories on the category of
quality and contrariety